so i'm joined here with evan carmichael
and we're discussing his busy schedule
now he's a big fan of the four-hour work
week apparently because
he only works three hours a day
mark's giving me a hard time so i'm in
the office about three hours a day so
this is my schedule
okay so monday i have my
monday tasks and things i do every week
writing anything that i have to do for
the week
i get it done monday my first tax so 10
15 every day i'm
in the office then i leave for so i do
an hour and a half
an hour and a half after an hour and a
half my brain starts to get fried so i
stop
i condense it all in then i go and i
take
a yoga class or zumba class or
pilates class and i'll come back in the
afternoon at 1 45
work another hour and a half and then
i'll go pick up my son and that's
usually it and i'll have some salsa
stuff whatever something in the
afternoon so essentially what you're
saying is you stroll in
at at 10 10 30. 10 15 10 15.
this is this yeah this is in school this
is this is
scheduled so it's all night so you
stroll in at 10 15
you you do a little bit of work for
about an hour and a half which
okay then then you take off and exercise
for workout number two
come back in work you know maybe answer
answer a few emails do do a bit of work
and then
and then you're out you're out by 3 p.m
this is this is less than
this is less than bankers hours this is
hardcore
focus work this is why i get pissed off
when people call me
interrupt me when i'm in the middle of
my work because if i'm only doing three
hours a day it's got to be
intense focused undistracted work
now now half an hour ago you mentioned
to me that you're you're busier now than
you've ever been could it be because
you're trying to do
a full-time work in only three hours a
day i am busy it is it is taxing
it is taxing it's fun though it's good
work it's good work
every day is something different life of
the entrepreneur